- What we have here is a zoom-in
of the surface of water.
So up here you have the
air, this is the air,
these are some air molecules,
maybe they're nitrogen molecules.
They're fairly far apart,
in fact, in reality,
they would be even more
far apart than this.
And then over here you
have water molecules.
We've seen this many times.
You have the oxygen atom and it's bonded
to two hydrogen atoms, and the oxygen atom
likes to hog the electrons more.
It's more electronegative, so you have
a partially negative charge at this end
and partially positive ends at this end.
And that attraction between the
partially positive ends and
the partially negative ends,
that's what gives water all
sorts of neat properties.
Those are the hydrogen bonds.
Those are the hydrogen
bonds that give water
all sorts of neat properties and keep it
in its liquid state at a standard
temperature and pressure.
Now what I want to think about
is the surface in particular.
And if you look at the surface of water,
it might look completely smooth.
But if you were to zoom
in on a molecular level,
you'll see that, well, it's
just made up of these molecules.
But roughly speaking, roughly speaking,
let's just say that this is roughly
the surface, the surface of the water.
The surface of the water.
Now, what's going on at the surface?
Well, all these molecules
are interacting through hydrogen bonds.
Let's say this molecule right over here,
it has hydrogen bonds
pulling on it upwards,
up to this one, pulling it this way,
pulling it downwards,
pulling it in really,
really, to some degree,
almost every direction.
And they all have their kinetic energy
and they're bumping around, but they're
flowing past each other.
The hydrogen bonds are
giving that cohesiveness.
The molecules are attracted to each other.
But if you look at the
molecules on the surface,
if you look at the ones on the surface,
sure, they might have
stuff pulling down on them,
they might have stuff
pulling them to the side,
but they don't have anything
pulling on them from above.
And because of this, you could imagine
that they're able to get a
little bit more densely packed,
little closer to their neighbors.
And this is what allows
them to actually have
a stronger, I guess you could
say, intermolecular force
at the surface than you
have within the body,
and that causes a phenomenon
known as surface tension.
So you have stronger, you
have kind of a deeper,
and this is still just hydrogen bonds,
but since they're not being pulled
in other directions
by, upwards by the air,
they're able to get a little
bit more closely packed,
a little bit tighter, and this we refer to
as surface tension, surface tension.
And you have probably
observed surface tension
many, many, many times in your life
in the form of, say, a water droplet.
A water droplet, it's able to
have this roughly round shape
because all the little water molecules
on the surface of the water droplet,
and here the surface might even be
on the bottom of the water droplet.
They are more attracted to each other
than they are to the surrounding air,
so they're able to form
this type of a shape.
You might've seen it if you go to a pond
or a stream sometimes, so
you see some still water.
And let's say, let me do this in blue.
So let's say that this is the surface
of the water right over here.
You might have seen
insects that are able to
walk on the surface of the water.
And I'm not doing a great
job at drawing the insects.
They don't look exactly like that.
But they can walk on the
surface of the water.
You might've seen or
you might've even tried
to do something like put
a paperclip on the water.
And even though this thing
is actually more dense
than the water and you
might expect it to sink,
but because of the surface tension,
which really forms something
of a film on top of the water,
the thing won't penetrate the surface,
so the paperclip will
float, unless you were to
push on it a little bit and it allow it
to puncture the surface, and then
it would actually sink, which
is what you would expect
because it is actually denser.
You'd even see this if
you were to take a cup,
if you were to take a cup
and you were to fill it
all the way up to the rim
and then a little bit higher,
it won't immediately overflow.
It won't immediately overflow.
If you're very careful, you'll see
that you form a bulge here.
And that bulges because those
individual water molecules
are more attracted to each other
than they are to the surrounding air.
So that allows for
something of a little bulge.
Obviously if you keep
pouring water, at some point,
they're just gonna start overflowing
because gravity's gonna take over there.
Gravity's gonna overwhelm
the surface tension.
But this bulge will actually form.
So surface tension, it is really due to
the cohesion of the water.
Remember, cohesion is when the molecules
are attracted to each other.
And it definitely, and
especially because they're
more attracted to each other
than the surrounding air.